.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
DEMOCRATS DESPERATELY TRYING TO
EXPLAIN AWAY CAR-A-LAGO WAS JOE
BIDEN HEADS BACK TO HIS DELAWARE
HOUSE TO REORGANIZE HIS GARAGE.
FALLOUT STILL COMING, FORCING
THE DOJ TO APPOINT A SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
ANYBODY VET THIS GUY?
YEP.
THE FBI GRILLING BIDEN AIDES
ABOUT HOW TOP-SECRET FILES ENDED
UP NEXT TO HIS CORVETTE.
WE'RE ALSO LEARNING THE SAME
HOUSE WAS HUNTER'S HANGOUT PAD.
THAT'S RIGHT, THE DRUG-LOVING
FIRST SON LIVED AT THE PROPERTY
PROPERTYFOR YEARS AND EVEN HAD S
CREDIT CARD STATEMENT SENT
THERE.
HE'D NEVER BE CARELESS ABOUT
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION, RIGHT?
>> DO YOU THINK IT'S
IRRESPONSIBLE AND RECKLESS OF
HIM?
>> IRRESPONSIBLE IS NOT TO
DISCLOSE WHEN YOU HAVE
DOCUMENTS.
HE'S CERTAINLY DONE THAT.
>> BIDEN PEOPLE ARE BRINGING
FORTH THE DOCUMENTS.
THEY'RE NOT OBSTRUCTING ACCESS
TO THEM OR KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THEM.
>> WHY DID HE NOT INFORM THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC TWO MONTHS AGO?
DO YOU THINK THAT WAS A MISTAKE?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING RIGHT NOW.
>> SEEM MUCH MORE MEASURED WITH
THIS THAN THE TRUMP DOCUMENTS.
YOU CALLED FOR TRANSPARENCY WITH
THE TRUMP DOCUMENTS.
>> BOTTOM LINE I SAID THAT NIGHT
IT'S PREMATURE TO COMMENT ON
WHAT SHOULD BE DONE.
>> AND NEITHER DOES PRESIDENT
BIDEN.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS STILL
TIGHTLIPPED OVER ALL THIS.
PETER DOOCY MAKES THIS
INTERESTING POINT.
>> IF I WOULD HAVE BEEN AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK A QUESTION,
THE FIRST ONE THAT I HAVE ON MY
SHEET WAS WHY IS PRESIDENT BIDEN
GOING TO WILMINGTON TODAY?
ISN'T THAT A POTENTIAL CRIME
SCENE?
>> HA-HA-HA.
THE FBI WAS JUST THERE THE OTHER
DAY.
>> THE AMAZING PART OF ALL OF
THIS IS THAT, YOU KNOW, WE KNOW
THAT THE LEFT DECIDES, LOOK,
THERE REALLY IS NOTHING TO SEE
HERE, BUT THE ISSUE IS NOT THE
NUMBER OF INADVERTENTLY
MISPLACED DOCUMENTS.
IT'S NOT WHETHER THERE WERE SO
FEW OR WHETHER HE'S FULLY
COOPERATING.
THE ISSUE IS WHETHER OR NOT HE
HAD DOCUMENTS.
HE WAS GROSSLY NEGLIGENT IN NOT
KEEPING THEM IN THE PROPER
STORAGE AREA.
THAT'S IT.
END.
STORY.
I DON'T KNOW WHY ALL OF A SUDDEN
THERE'S THIS WHAT-ABOUTISM.
WHAT I WANT TO KNOW IF HUNTER
BIDEN LIVED IN THAT HOUSE, WHERE
THERE WERE DOCUMENTS IN THAT
GARAGE -- BY THE WAY, THE GARAGE
DOOR HAS BEEN LEFT OPEN IN THE
PAST, THAT'S BEEN REPORTED ON,
AND THE DOCUMENTS WERE RIGHT
THERE -- THE DOCUMENTS HAVE BEEN
THERE AT LEAST SIX YEARS,
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN SIX YEARS
SINCE JOE BIDEN WAS THE VICE
PRESIDENT, THEN THE QUESTION IS,
WHO HAD ACCESS TO THOSE
DOCUMENTS?
IF HUNTER WAS LIVING THERE, I
WANT SOMEONE TO FINGERPRINT
THOSE DOCUMENTS.
I WANT THOSE DOCUMENTS
FINGERPRINTED SO I KNOW THAT
HUNTER BIDEN WAS DEFINITELY NOT
TOUCHED THEM, BECAUSE I SUSPECT
THAT THERE'S MORE TO IT.
IN ADDITION, NOW WE'VE GOT THREE
LOCATIONS.
IN ADDITION TO THE GARAGE,
THERE'S ANOTHER LOCATION IN THE
HOUSE.
AND CAREEN JEAN-PIERRE KNEW ON
WEDNESDAY THAT THERE WAS AN
ADDITIONAL LOCATION OF THESE
DOCUMENTS.
THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, THEY
SHUT DOWN THE HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP.
OKAY?
THEY DIDN'T WANT ANYBODY TO KNOW
ABOUT IT.
SOMETHING LIKE 52% OF AMERICANS
SAY THEY WOULD HAVE CHANGED
THEIR VOTES IN A CLOSE ELECTION.
NOW WE'VE GOT THEM DOING THE
SAME THING BEFORE A MIDTERM,
HIDING WHAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND THE WHITE HOUSE
KNEW.
AND THEY ARE NOW, LIKE THEY'RE
GASLIGHTING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
FINALLY I THINK THAT IT IS WORTH
ASKING HOW AND WHY THIS STORY IS
BREAKING NOW.
IS THIS SOME OF THE DEMS WHO
DON'T WANT JOE BIDEN TO RUN?
EVERYBODY HAS KNOWN ABOUT THIS
FOR MONTHS IN, WITH.
NOW ARE THEY LEAKING IT SO THEY
CAN SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT, WE'RE
GOING TO TANK JOE BIDEN AND GET
HIM THE HELL OUT.
>> DO YOU FIND THAT SUSPICIOUS,
GERALDO?
>> YOU MEAN THE TIMING OF THIS?
>> THE TIMING AND --
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, I'M SO
SCORNFUL OF THIS STORY.
I THINK IT'S A BIG WASTE OF
TIME.
I THINK YOU SHOULD SCOLD BOTH OF
THESE GUYS.
YOU SHOULD REVOKE THEIR LIBRARY
CARDS.
>> THEIR LIBRARY CARDS?
>> LET'S GET ON WITH LIFE.
ALL OF THIS HUBRIS, ALL OF THIS
ENERGY, THIS MONEY, THIS SPECIAL
COUNSEL, I PREDICT YOU'LL SEE
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL -- IT'S
GOING TO BE LIKE A SPARKLER ON
JULY 4th, BURNING DOWN, AND
THEN ON TO OTHER THINGS.
>> TRUMP OR BIDEN, NOTHING IS
GOING TO HAPPEN?
>> NOTHING SHOULD HAPPEN.
I'M NOT SAYING NOTHING IS GOING
TO HAPPEN.
WHEN YOU EXAMINE THIS, WHAT
EXACTLY HAPPENED HERE?
THE PRESIDENTS OF THE UNITED
STATES TOOK STUFF THAT WASN'T
THEIRS BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO
EGO STROKE, WRITE A BOOK,
WHATEVER --
>> VICE PRESIDENT.
>> HE WAS VICE PRESIDENT ENOUGH.
>> IT'S A LEGAL TERM.
>> THEY KEPT THEM, IGNORED THEM.
HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE BOXES THAT
ULPUT IN THE GARAGE, AND YOU
LEAVE THEM THERE, AND THEY GET
WET AND --
>> WITH CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS?
>> BELIEVE ME, BOXES IN GARAGES
ARE AN INDICATION OF HOW
IMPORTANT THE VICE PRESIDENT
THOUGHT THIS WAS.
>> HE SAID HE TAKES IT VERY
SERIOUSLY.
ARE BOXES IN A GARAGE GETTING
WET TAKING IT SERIOUSLY,
GERALDO?
>> I THINK THAT -- I DO NOT TAKE
IT SERIOUSLY.
I'M SORRY.
I WILL SIT AND --
>> WASHINGTON, D.C. TAKES IT
VERY SERIOUSLY.
>> ALL OF THE RAGE, ALL OF THE
EMOTION, ALL OF THE ENGAGEMENT
THAT YOU'RE SEEKING --
>> BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CHINA RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT UKRAINE.
>> WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT.
>> YES, WE ARE.
ON CABLE NEWS TODAY?
YOU'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT?
>> OH, REALLY?
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS.
>> THESE DOCUMENTS ARE ABOUT THE
UKRAINE, JOE BIDEN GOES TO MEET
WITH THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
FOUR DAYS BEFORE HE TAKES
OFFICE.
WHAT KIND OF DEALS DO THEY HAVE
COOKING?
>> I'VE BEEN WATCHING RIVETING
JOURNALISM ON YOUR SHOW.
LAST NIGHT YOU CREATED AN
EPIPHANY IN MY HEAD, TYING IT
TOGETHER IN A NICE BOW.
JUDGE JEANINE, THEY ARE
CONNECTED TO ONE THING.
WHAT IS THE ONE THING IN COMMON?
HUNTER BIDEN.
THE BIG GUY PROBABLY DIDN'T KNOW
WHO HAD THOSE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, BECAUSE HE GAVE HIS
SON ONE JOB, GET RID OF THE
STUFF THAT CONNECTS TO THE BIG
GUY.
HE WAS SUPPOSED TO THROW THE GUN
IN THE GARAGE AND SUPPOSED TO
PUT THE DOCUMENTS IN THE TRASH.
YOU HAD ONE JOB.
>> AND LEAVE THE CANNOLI.
>> YES.
HE HAD ACCESS.
HE'S BEEN TO THE WHITE HOUSE TO
SEE THE BIG GUY.
THIS WILL LEAD TO THE INDICTMENT
OF HUNTER FOR WHAT HE DID, WHICH
WILL THEN, TO YOUR POINT, SCORN
THE LITTLE GIRL THAT HE MADE
TAKE A BUS WHEN SHE DIDN'T WANT
TO, KAMALA, REVENGE IS BEST
SERVED COLD.
SO HE WILL PARDON HIS SON AND
RESIGN.
KAMALA GETS A THING IN ONE TIGHT
LITTLE BOW.
>> OH, WOW.
THAT WOULD BE ONE SPECIAL
MOMENT.
>> LAPTOP.
I'M TELLING YOU.
>> WHAT BOTHERS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ABOUT THIS, THERE'S A
DOUBLE STANDARD.
LEAVE HIM ALONE.
NO BIG DEAL.
HILLARY CLINTON HAD 110 EMAIL
CHAINS WITH SEVERAL TOP-SECRET
DOCUMENTS AMONG THEM, AND WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO SAY IT'S OKAY, AND
JIM COMEY GETS UP AND SAYS WE'RE
NOT GOING TO PROSECUTE IN THIS
CASE.
OTHER FOLKS, A FORMER CIVILIAN
EMPLOYEE OF THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT, PUT TOGETHER BY JIM
GARRITY, SPENT MONTHS IN PRISON
FOR BRINGING CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS BACK TO THEIR HOUSE.
ANOTHER, 18 MONTHS IN PRISON,
$10,000 CRIME, FOR WILLFULLY
DETAINING NATIONAL DEFENSE
INFORMATION.
ANOTHER ONE GOT NINE YEARS IN A
FEDERAL PRISON.
GERALDO, CAN YOU --
>> NINE YEARS IS AN ESPIONAGE.
>> WHY DO THE RULES NOT PERTAIN
TO THE PRESIDENT OR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT?
>> I'LL ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
WITH A QUESTION.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THE FACT,
AS JEANINE POINTS OUT, THIS WAS
THE DAY BEFORE THE MIDTERMS,
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, THE
PURPORTED PROXIMITY MAKES IT SO
RELEVANT AND SO FORTH?
WHAT IF THIS ELECTION COMING UP,
OR THE CANDIDACY OF EITHER OF
THESE GENTLEMEN, TURNS ON THIS
CRAP?
ON NEGLIGENCE.
YOU KNOW, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
THEY WEREN'T SHOPLIFTERS.
SHE WEREN'T CROOKS.
THEY WERE SLOPPY.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE FACT THAT
HILLARY AND JOE, WHEN THESE
THINGS HAPPENED --
>> LOOK, THIS IS BENGHAZI.
THIS IS BENGHAZI AGAIN.
>> GERALDO, YOU'RE NOT ANSWERING
MY QUESTION.
WHY DO THESE CIVILIANS HAVE TO
FOLLOW THE LAW OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA?
WHY IS IT THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS
THINK THEY'RE ABOVE THE LAW?
I HEARD NANCY PELOSI SCREAMING
ABOUT THE FACT THAT NO ONE IS
ABOVE THE LAW.
NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW, HILLARY
CLINTON, WHEN IT COMES TO DONALD
TRUMP.
WHY ARE THEY ABOVE THE LAW?
IF I'M LEAVING THE WHITE HOUSE
AND I'VE GOT CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS I'M GOING, GUYS, CHECK
EVERYTHING.
I'M NOT WALKING OUT OF HERE WITH
ANYTHING.
>> THIS IS A LOT DIFFERENT THAN
A CIVIL SERVANT, TRYING TO SAVE
HIMSELF SOME WEAR AND TEAR BY
TAKING SOMETHING HOME.
THAT'S AN ARROGANT MOVE BY A
BUREAUCRAT WHO DESERVES TO HAVE
HIS WRISTS SLASHED.
>> WHY IS THIS NOT AN AIR GANT
MOVE BY A BUREAUCRAT?
>> BECAUSE HE WAS THE VICE
PRESIDENT OR PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> HE'S THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, WHERE
NATIONAL SECURITY IS THE TOP
ISSUE RIGHT NOW.
AND THIS GUY IS NOT ONLY IN BED
WITH CHINA, AND GETTING MONEY
FROM CHINA THROUGH HIS SON, HE'S
GOT THE 10% -- WE'RE TALKING
NATIONAL SECURITY HERE.
>> WERE YOU THIS PASSIONATE WHEN
IT WAS MAR-A-LAGO AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT IN BED
WITH RUSSIA, CHINA OR ANYBODY
ELSE.
>> OH, COME ON.
THAT'S POLITICS.
>> GERAL